welcome guys to strategy session and as
I was just saying we're gonna do some
gameplay I'll try and make this
interactive so you guys can suggest
openings suggest moves and we'll try and
be as many players as possible last week
I did this and we lost the first game
and it was is really sad so this time
we'll try and stay clean and try and
play some good quality chess so what I'm
gonna do is join the hourly rapid arena
which is one of the main tournaments on
me chess I think it happens every hour
every two hours and it's an easy way to
get a game this one is a two hour long
tournament ten plus zero so there's
gonna be no increment just ten minutes
per side and game is starting or playing
Monta caseros
okay he was oh we got reigning points -
I'm really sorry about that that usually
doesn't happen but last time it happened
where the guy left mid game and then the
previous time someone left after four
moves okay so we're in 50th place I'll
explain how the tournament works because
every game you win you get points after
that game we won two tournaments if
we're on a streak we get 1 additional
points so we need to to keep winning
games to maximize the number of points
we gain if a game doesn't start in the
next 30 seconds we might switch the
lobby just to get a quicker game I
really don't know what's going on here
okay there we go
we have UD Agha let's play d4 and if he
plays d5 will play a Queen's Gambit he
plays c5 this is kind of a reverse
Queens gambit where he's offering us
upon I'm gonna go ahead here and play
what I normally play I will say that the
best and most principled move is d5
and then goes into Bernoulli I'm gonna
take on c5 and there's a very specific
way like can play this to try and give
black problems from early on so he plays
e6 I'm gonna play Knight c3 and the idea
here is that he takes on c5 and now I'll
go for 94 and now I'm attacking the
bishop and the square on d6 is very weak
and this is something I've played many
times before we're gonna go in and
invade with 96 and he's gonna take we're
gonna take back with the Queen this is
already like a comfortable position for
whites now he is moving very quickly
this is a rapid chess but we already
have the bishop pair we have a queen
pretty much in the heart of his position
now after ninety seven he wants to play
that at five and attack the Queen so I'm
just gonna play e4 just a useful center
grabbing move controlling space and now
it's probably time to develop the rest
of the white pieces probably should
focus on King side development I'm gonna
play the most flexible move Knight f3 so
I'm not entirely sure where these
bishops would like to end up feel free
if anyone wants to suggest and move here
I'm thinking that yeah I'm thinking the
light square Bishop should develop first
so so I can just castle Bishop e2 looks
very safe so I don't really see a
purpose for the Bishop coming to c4 yeah
I like Bishop e2 and we can see the
Queen is actually causing him a lot of
problems because there's no immediate
way for him to attack the Queen because
this pawn is very nicely placed
restricting the Knights so he's
appearing to try to to kind of develop
around the Queen okay now it makes sense
I think just a castle complete
development and one of the main
advantages White has in this position is
control over the half-open d-file
so we would like together rook to d1
rook t1 is playable right away and
simply to attack the pawn another option
would be developing the bishop first
maybe Bishop g5 or Bishop f4
I'm gonna play rook t1 putting immediate
pressure and putting him in a situation
where okay if he wants to defend the
pawn it might be it is not the most
attractive move for him but now he is
attacking the pawn on e4 so so we can
look to the fend the pawn we can look to
counter-attack Bishop g5 could be a
counter attacking option but it could
run into f6 I do like the position for a
white though and I'm looking for
resources here
yeah pawn to e5 is an option but it
opens up his bishop and it opens up the
five square for his knights
so I think the pawn should be reinforced
on on e4 one moves like one that comes
to mind that maybe doesn't look that
attractive but simply Bishop d3 just to
defend the pawn and keep all the tension
in the position another move would be
retreating the Queen to like f4 a d4
because there is a time limit let's play
Bishop d3 I think this keeps the most
amount of tension next move
whoa Knight c8 is undeveloped ting well
now we have to move the Queen let's drop
back to g3 if we notice most of his
pieces are just so passive on the Queen
side and a good number of our pieces
have potential to attack on the Kings
side like already there's some idea of
Bishop h6
so Bishop f4 is one move attacking the
Knights right
I mean Bishop h6 also looks really
attractive because we're threatening
made in one and I'm not sure how he
defends like if he plays Queen f6 or
maybe that defense we play e5 but then
he takes our Bishop so we could play e5
first with the threat of Bishop h6 I
actually really liked e5 because so
we're not planning Bishop f4 we're
planning Bishop h6 and in playing E 5
were essentially opening up the other
Bishop 2 so now we have 4 potentially
very strong attackers and he has so many
pieces out of play
doing almost nothing so the situation is
good for us but it still might be hard
to execute the attack
so Bishop h6 is an option but then he
can play Queen e7 I think it makes sense
to to take on passant to open to keep
this diagonal open even though we give
him some center so he takes back with
the Queen so Bishop g5 is one move but
then he might go pawn grabbing that
could be very playable for whites but it
might require to some calculation so
let's imagine Bishop g5 queen take b2
and may be Queen h4 threatening h7
Queen h3 immediately Oh after okay
Bishop g5 Queen's a p-223 is a nice
smooth threatening East six as well
threatening h7 black can't defend both
let's go for that yeah I really like
that screen take b2 it looks wrong okay
he doesn't go for it he keeps keeps
things trying to keep things defended
but now 95 looks really attractive this
is a nice tempo move attacking the Queen
improving the Knights his Queen has to
move again I think his Queen will
probably move here unless he wants to
retreat to one of these ways so he plays
queen h5 and it's still up to us to
continuous on attack and perhaps it's
not the easiest position to get anything
immediate and a position like this
because our time is low I'm just gonna
play a natural improving move rook e1
yeah when you don't see much you just
want to improve your pieces especially
when you're down on time rookie wantings
to perhaps target this this backward
pawn in the long term and sorry and also
okay if we have removed the knight the
pawns not defended so we could have some
simple discover attacks like 9f three or
even I'm imagining if he plays a knight
to c6 we could play Knight d7 plays
Knight d6
well now this night is undefended and
there's a move I think there's a very
simple tactic here Bishop e7 though
maybe it's not so simple because Bishop
e7 could be met with Knight f5 then we
could take it he takes with rook mm-hmm
looks very close but well the night's
still on e5
so Bishop e7 Knight f5 at some point I'm
gonna have to just start moving a lot
quicker I'm gonna play Knight to f3
because this unleashes a rook and
unleashes the Queen and it over defends
a bishop
ok he's moving very quickly I think we
should take the Knights because it's an
annoying piece too late because we're
low on time we gotta I gotta move much
quicker let's play Knight to d4
pressuring the pond he has double pawns
here which are both potentially weak at
some point I might switch gears
completely and focus just on positional
chess I might just want to solidify it
at some point with Bishop to e3 put
their work on d1 and be in a spot where
I can play much quicker moves I'm gonna
start with rook D one another idea is to
play B 3 and C 4 trying restrict his
Bishop sorry ok let's move the bishop
back to e3 a big component especially of
these like 10 McCain's is moving quickly
time management time management in the
opening probably it wasn't that great
it's always hard to play and give
commentary and manage time but ok so he
wants to play rook to g6
I don't think there's a huge threat with
that because the Queen could perhaps
come into his territory
maybe we can even start with something
like Queen c7 yeah I'm gonna start with
Queen c7 aggressive-looking move the
Queen still kind of defends from afar
and that also has a lot of pet attacking
potentials and now we are threatening c4
that's very true and c4 actually traps
his bishop didn't even realize that but
okay so he wants to trade Queens so I'm
thinking Queen CH is one option and he
could block with the Queen then we can
trade I'm gonna start with Queen the
problem with Queen c8 he could play this
and then he's threatening Bishop to d7
I'm in the trade Queens because I know
the the position is good positionally
just based on the structure and then b3
is coming next
yeah and now we want to play C for and
the threat of c4 is to make the bishop
move so we can win e six pawn yeah
and he can't play d5 to stop it he
probably has to defend the pawn like he
probably has to play one of these moves
except he doesn't knight c6 is playable
we could take I like Knight be 5 because
we avoid the trade were threatening to
trap the bishop we have threats of 96
maybe targeting the pawn in the rook the
time is still a factor that's an
interesting move because if we play c4
then the square is weak
Bishop d4 is one option bishop d4 and
then c4 yeah let's go for that so the
problem with c4 oh is 93 could be very
annoying in some some lines in this case
we're chasing the night away to more
passive square and now c4 and then we'll
get 96 and we'll try and keep the
initiative and try and keep moving
quickly to sorry yeah night 84 should be
coming I'm a little bit scared that he
might have rook d7 with counter play
though I'm thinking that maybe we should
go for B for C 5 but oh wait yeah sorry
the knight is hanging that's that's a
very good point
a Bishop e3 rook here okay we're gonna
take on e4 well but then he still has
rook t8 this is actually very unpleasant
maybe Bishop b2 and then Bishop a3 and
then we somehow survive I do apologize
for for time management overall but
we're still alive Bishop e3 and now we
would like to play d4 c5 except he can
still take the knight so we might have
to double up 93's a threat let's play
rook to e3
positions a bit shaky 93 but now we're
unpinned I think we can take the pawn
now you take f2 I know it looks scary
but I think we survived after rocked 87
I mean it could get very tactical very
soon I'm gonna start pre moving while I
can okay let's take and then I'm gonna
bring the knight mmm
he's threatening mate so f3 just
defending if he takes our tonight we
take back with rook and we can attack
his Knight I am capable of moving fast
so there is still hope
but he's attacking upon let's defend it
Knight c3
and yet we want to play King g3 at some
points except you can play g5 so let's
play Bishop d6 attacking the Knights the
position objectively is good for whites
if we don't look at time but it's about
winning this in 30 seconds ooh
interesting let's do this
okay he's winning upon but we're gonna
play h5 and now it's the time scramble
let's play rook d3 I want to play g4 and
then rip d6 or King III and move the
knight I'm imagining a night here and a
rook here delivering mates I could take
a while but maybe it's possible in 24
seconds I'm happy as rook is completely
out of play
maybe King g3 at some points where it's
safer how King III defending the rook
okay we're going to take
at hold tight let's defend the pawn with
44 17 seconds Oh Bishop d6 that's a move
okay now we're threatening 95 we're
threatening the rook I think white is
winning material
yeah where we win material not much time
left
yeah he might move the bishop and then
we might meet him my bishop they got 396
and we're threatening made in two and
how does he defend rook b2 King c1 f
king f7 we still play Rupp d8 okay so
he's created a open square so we're
gonna push up on ten seconds left
woo that was probably a bad move but we
can come back with the Knights
does anyone see mate looking for maid
here
I pretty much okay
I keep pre moving so I could bill out
with a draw at some point but this this
is a winning endgame I'm gonna try and
win this because it's OPS's Collier
bishops and his King is boxed out and
the great thing on me chess is when you
pre move you don't lose any time and
just calm yeah you would lose time but
I'll meet us I'm gonna try and play this
for a while
yes the play King g6 to save the bishop
we win a pawn because discover check ok
we won one pawn that was nice
now we have to somehow either meet the
king or win the bishop this is an easily
winning endgame and we would have more
time but it's not so easy when you have
to pre move every move and the key is to
pre move on dark space yeah he could
start moving really quickly which would
probably be a good strategy but he can't
move too quickly because I can continue
making threats
no the rook was defended by the bishop
I could I could take the bishop anytime
I want but I don't want to take the
bishop
okay we're gonna try it to meet with
just the king in the rook it's difficult
oh no I dropped the rook okay I think I
can just repeat oh no I dropped the
bishop and this is a loss unless he
repeats now this is winning for him
we're gonna pray for stalemate somehow
Oh ruff is very rough I'm sure he's very
happy to have won that game sometimes
that's what happens when you play for a
win actually the the resulting endgame I
think is really interesting to try and
demonstrate how to win this this
position because his bishop or because
his pawn and Bishop defend each other it
is actually somewhat of a difficult
position
so when even if you have a lot of time
because you have to somehow chase the
king and that game how long was that
game that game was 136 moves probably
most of the moves I played with pre
moving and a 10-minute game yeah so what
I would like to do yeah I want to show
you guys actually a cool feature in me
chess which not too many people are
aware of and it applies in positions
with 6 or less pieces on the board which
would be this position we count the
number of pieces there's exactly six I
hope you guys know this but
to any position that has six or less
pieces is solved have you guys heard of
a table base anyone so table base is
essentially a database of like all the
positions which exists of 6 or less
position or 6 or less pieces on the
board and lead chess has it built in for
free to access it you can click this
button right here it's also the opening
Explorer which is another tool but if we
click it we can see that there's a lot
of winning moves for whites and the cool
thing is it will show basically all the
legal moves and show how quickly they
will lead to a win now we see this kind
of weird this weird kind of acronym DTZ
which stands for distance to zeroing we
see DTZ 32 what this means is that it
takes 32 half moves until the next
capture so basically until the the 50
move rule resets the 15 move role being
if if 50 moves go by with no captures or
no pawn moves in it it's a draw so
essentially in 16 moves white will be
able to force a capture and instead of
showing you how to win this I'm gonna
have table base show us how to win this
and we'll see we'll try and make some
sense of of the moves that it suggests
so it's a start with Bishop g1 ok let's
say black keeps waiting that says rook
e1 black will keep waiting and then rook
d1 and now this makes sense to try and
use the rook the King and the bishop to
drive the King towards towards edge of
the board while keeping watch of the
pond so I'll keep clicking through the
top moves here rook d4 makes a lot of
sense and some of the ideas apply from
that like the basic rook checkmate what
do you want to box a king in with just
your rook ok so now we walk up the King
rook h4 o work h4 is a nice waiting move
given that we just cut off the king and
and it's its Discoverer a check - so the
king is driving back King e6 waits with
the Bishop rook h5 so it seems like
white keeps making the Box smaller and
will keep clicking here and it seems
like there's a repeating pattern of some
sorts and the king is finally driven
towards the edge and now king a7 would
be would be made in one so Bishop f1 and
now and now really nice and move from
like Bishop to b6 threatening made in
one the only defense is to give up the
pawn looks like Bishop b5 would be the
best try let's say Bishop to b5 and then
rook take h3 once white wins upon then
then the number is reset and now we
actually see DTM DTM means distance to
mate and we'll just I'll just click
through the top line just to show how
light will eventually win takes the
bishop and I don't think we have to go
any further this is just winning but it
is cool to kind of use table base to see
if a certain endgame is winning or drawn
and some end games can be very very
complex where DT D what does that mean
Oh distance to draw know if it's a
drawing endgame it just says draw and it
doesn't give you a distance to anything
anyway
try and find some instructive value from
this game I'll show you guys another
tool in me chest which is actually good
for analyzing your own games which I
think leech s already did or it's in the
process of doing where it will go
through and basically find all the
blunders and mistakes now it's taking a
really long time here it gives a game is
over a hundred thirty moves so it's it's
going through every single move and
about
with engine and trying to find where we
might wrong sorry so sometimes it does
it automatically if it doesn't do it
automatically what you can do is usually
below the board it will give you a
button that says request computer
analysis and you just click on that and
it will it will analyze it so maybe I
can show you an example of another game
I played that has computer analysis
already used like let's say this game
and also spord oh like okay but like
right here you see the bun request
computer analysis if we click that then
it will start analyzing and then once
it's done it usually takes a few minutes
then it'll give you a bunch of
statistics where it shows the blunders
and mistakes and that inaccuracies and
it's a really nice tool if you want to
kind of quickly go over a game oh so if
you play yeah so I I can do a quick demo
here and just show how to do it if you
play like an over the board game and you
want to analyze and we chess so yeah
we'll switch gears will probably save
time for like one more game towards the
end but I think this will be useful for
people to to know how to do because it's
a great kind of self-study method so
what you can do if you want to access
the tools that all the tools built into
lis chess you go to learn and study
after anyone's familiar with chess space
this is kind of me chesses version of
kinda many of the tools in chef space
where we can go create new study and it
gives us a bunch of options here I'm
just going to call this strategy session
and if you want to you can make it
public to the whole world I'll leave it
as public you can allow people to
collaborate for this one I'll just click
starts and let's say you play in the
tournament
and you have the score sheet you have
the game and you want to put it in me
chests
what you can do is just start with
initial position can maybe name it your
name risk is your opponent's name can
say like Rosen Carlson or whatever and
then you just enter the moves like
normal recommend I recommend entering
the moves without having the engine
turned on at least at the beginning and
try and try and arrive at your own
conclusions if you wanted to access just
stock fish and just have the stock fish
recommendations you can access it with
this toggle right here and stock fish
it'll spit out a number and it's usually
usually does a good job of giving you an
idea of who's better in the position
let's say we make a really bad blender
for light and we play Bishop Asics then
stock fish will say minus three and the
valuation is basically how many pawns
one side is down so if it says minus
three white is down the equivalent of
about three and a half plots here which
makes sense because the bishop is worth
about three points and black can just
take the bishop and usually if one side
has like an advantage of a plus 2 or
minus 2 then it's considered a winning
advantage let's say you play the whole
game and you want the computer analysis
on the full game let's actually I'll
just show a quick miniature yeah I'm
about to show that but we need a game
first so I'm going to show a quick
miniature in the caro-kann I should also
note you can add sub variations like it
has here if I wanted to make this a
mainline I just right click make me in
line I can delete the other variation if
I wanted to so the game I'm about to
show it's a it's a 5 move game I played
many years ago as a young kid and I used
an opening trap from this position
I played Queen e2 I was playing against
a much older guy and he played Knight
gf6 and then does anyone want to say the
next move but I played 96 Meek's so
let's say this is a game I want to
emili´s now I should rename this this is
not Rosen Carlson mrs. Rosen some guy
and what we can do is go below the board
and it gives us a bunch of options if we
wanted to like annotate it we can like
give an ex slam for good move and this
is useful if you're like building out
your preparation or reading from a book
and you want to save the like the
annotations but we can go to computer
analysis and then simply request
analysis and this should take pretty
pretty quickly just hopefully a few
seconds actually it already gives us
analysis that was really quick and if
you see here it gives what's called the
average sent upon loss which it's a bit
difficult to explain if you google
average sent upon loss you'll find a
pretty good definition but essentially
the lower the sent upon loss the closer
to perfection one side played according
to the engine so if you have a sense
upon loss of zero then you play the
perfect game according to the engine we
can see in this position blacks average
sent upon loss is 213 which is which is
really bad anything over a hundred is
not that great and it was just because
of this really big blunder in Knight f6
where if clack played something like e
six then it wouldn't be so bad for black
I'm actually surprised so the the engine
will automatically like give some
annotations here I'm a bit surprised
that it says Queen e2 is a fine move
because Queen e2 in my opinion is a
dubious move given that at blocks of
Bishop and it's it's basically a hope
move hoping for hoping that black falls
for some other it means but yeah this is
a really nice tool if you're playing
online or if you're playing in a
tournament and you want to save all of
your games in the digital formats and
the great thing here you can save a
collection of games this is chapter one
if we wanted to add a new chapter we
just just click add new
after let's say if we wanted this
chapter to be a position and not
necessarily a game I could add that here
could empty bored and I could maybe show
some endgame position so I use this a
lot for my own studies but I also use it
for teaching where it's just great kind
of organized material and then if I make
a public study than anyone can access it
and just to show this one example of the
table base this would be a drawn a drawn
endgame and the table base just shows
basically every move is drawn for black
except a few moves are losing exactly
three moves are losing yeah
so don't play any of those moves so any
questions about this anything you want
me to explain in more detail if not I
think we can try and play another game
and hopefully redeem ourselves and and
not in a good note so I don't think
we'll have time for a 10-minute game but
we'll try and get it in like a boots
game and I will try to play a lot faster
than the previous game yeah so let's
pause the tournament let's go back to
the home page we can play five plus
three this is this is the easiest way to
start the game you just click and it
should eventually pair us we could also
look to see who's seeking a game we
could play this guy five plus four
Lincoln one and we're black you want
Sicilian okay well place the ceiling any
specific variation dragon okay
hyperaccelerated okay it's very specific
so G six here okay
Oh D 3 D 3 is a passive move but
normally we can just continue with the
dragon setup we'll play D 6 play Knight
f6 and Castle looks like he might be
going for an eventual d4 usually in
these clothes structures where they they
don't really challenge the center
immediately it's good idea to expound on
the queenside so I'm gonna go for that
right away with b5 and even support it
with rook b8 and usually you want to
attack in the direction that your plan
chain is pointing so if you have a pawn
chain and it's pointing towards one side
then most of the time it makes sense to
attack on that side so that's what I'm
doing here and the pawn chain actually
combines very well with this Bishop on
g7 because the pawns and the bishop work
together to control a lot of key squares
in the center it's one of the nice
things about playing the dragon no just
keep improving the position Queen b6 I'm
gonna go for Bishop a6 very soon just
complete developments except after C for
the bishop doesn't have much purpose on
a six-song the play Bishop d7 and one
square which looks really weak in his
territory is this d4 square so I play 97
to unleash the bishop targeting d4 he
wants to play Bishop b2 and neutralize
everything which may be not a bad plan
so I'm gonna jump in immediately and I
would be completely ok if he takes I
would probably take back with a pawn
because a pawn on d4 controls some some
nice space it kicks away the Knights and
the position transforms a little bit we
have the knight having access now to c5
he is threatening this pawn to play e6
oh the Queen okay thanks for thanks for
alarming me that would have been really
tragic
we could take yeah we could take the
Knights we could also play Queen d8
again sometimes it's hard to talk and
and play like
accurately but the night could be a
problem trim like if we play Quincy it
than he sixes might gets kicked around
I'm gonna leave uh yeah I'm gonna leave
the bishop on the board and go 406 next
move
now this night actually only has one
safe square on f4 where it looks really
awkward then we could potentially play
g5 Bishop g5 maybe f6 it looks really
ugly but the bishop has to move then we
play e6 this pawn is attacked that one I
see let's play let's play at six cuz
yeah the bishop has to move if it moves
back then we play e6 Knight f4 and then
g5 and we fork if the bishop moves here
we trap the Knights okay we're about to
fork him except if he plays nine afore
he's threatening to fork us so the the
name of the game is don't get forked
which the st. Louis chess club actually
has a whole series of YouTube videos
called don't get forked
it's like a whole game show type format
Ryan Chester does it rook e8 is one move
I like Knight c5 it's a bit more active
we defend the knight can't really get
kicked around and the amazing thing here
is we're threatening the fork I was
about to say we're also trying to trap
the night but he has a knight h5 both of
the bishop defense so I don't want to
give him that square right away I'm
gonna start with Queenie eights Oh II
five then he goes back yeah I don't want
to make any commitments too soon
so a4 is one idea I just don't want it
to be in his favorite cuz he could take
and open the file let's improve the
bishop the bishop has no purpose on g7
it has more purpose on h6 he might play
Knight h3 then he would be attacking the
pawn and then I'll go for rip d8 and
just defend very unusual position the
strange pawn structure now he's
expanding how e5 looks slightly tempting
at five but then we take in that Bishop
opens up I'm gonna go for a 5 there's
not too much time
now I should know them this game there's
an increment and yeah if if his pawn
goes away.we that we would have Bishop
to e3
rook f1 bishop c8 is definitely a move
which I think it just improves the
position because the bishop doesn't like
to be staring it like a really solid
pawn it likes the more open diagonal at
some point I might like to play King h8
to where if he ever does play f5 we
would like to take and have a rook on g8
to control the open G file so let's play
King h8 this is just a quick improving
move
I'm already fantasizing about somehow
getting our Knight to e3 that could take
a very long time but it's a close
position so we might have time to
rearrange things I'm also looking at
maybe ideas of a Bishop e6 and Queen d7
but okay he takes probably take with
this pawn now we no longer have double
pawns and there might be some idea of
playing f5 Bishop e3 I like very much
what did you want to say yeah but it's
it's not a dangerous pass pawn
technically it is a passed pawn but it's
not going anywhere and yeah I like this
position like black has some space
advantage the bishop on e3 is very
annoying
I play Bishop e6 because I want to play
Queen d7 and I would like to keep
improving I don't want to trade bishops
the rule is when you have a space
advantage you should avoid trading minor
pieces and the idea is to just slowly
build up like Queen d7 rook f7 and rook
DF fades
bishop take Knights a bishop at four
maybe it's possibility g4 kind of coming
out of nowhere he's trying to be
aggressive Queen d7 looks very
attractive yeah because if he plays g5
we can take the knight and then attack
the rook and meanwhile we're just
attacking g4 so I'm expecting probably
erupted e1 or King g3 some point very
soon f5 will be a major idea so he plays
Queens e1 I'm gonna start with rook f7
yeah there's no rush and usually if you
have a pawn break in mind you want to
optimize your pieces and then carry
through with a pawn break because the
rule is when the position opens up it's
gonna favor who's ever pieces are better
better placed if we optimize all the
pieces and black bowl will just have a
better setup and whites pieces are not
too impressive here and hey we have a
time advantage it's a miracle
okay let's play rook to f8 seems like he
wants to play g5 but he doesn't want to
open that file
maybe Bishop back to e3 nice quick move
always nice when you can play quick move
with tempo but again we probably don't
want to trade so we'll repeat once and
now okay now I'm thinking about f5
because if he plays g5 we could take and
then attack the Knights and if he takes
with the e pawn we take with F pawn and
then if g5 we retreat the bishop
oh he plays Bishop h5 they're attacking
the rook we can slide the rook over yeah
let's go for f5 actually no I'm gonna
play Queen d6 verse there's no rush and
I want the Queen on the same time though
the King so if he ever would take with
the e pawn okay he really wants to trade
the bishops let's turn him down because
that five is coming yeah an LM Ally
chess master
there's no rating requirement you you
technically have to be I think the
language they use you have to be a
goodly chess citizen so you basically
have to like behave well on the site and
help people like in the forum's but
let's focus on on this game
now if f5 Knight g5 could happen so this
might be a long grind I don't want to do
anything too committal
ing five we could play h6 and then you
could play h5 okay I'm gonna play a
waiting move maybe have some idea of
playing a four even though it's probably
not realistic there's also some idea of
playing 96 to control g5 and maybe put
the bishop back on c6 very close
position okay he wants to double up yeah
f5 f5 looks attractive here because my
g5 is currently not too threatening
because we can take if he ever takes
with the pawn will have this discovered
check and if he does nothing we would
probably want to play f4 or maybe even
just take I'll have some good options so
he plays my g5 so let's just take and f4
is probably coming
well it depends okay he takes with pawn
so we have a choice between f4 and
taking taking looks really attractive
because I don't see how you saves
material because we calculate rook take
f7 rook take out seven pawn to e4 will
have rook F 2 in the end oh but then he
has ripped g2 but at least we'll have a
nice defended passed pawn those pawns
are doubled but they're they're well
defended okay I'm gonna go for a rookie
to
yeah Brooke take e to in d3 rights it
should just win material he has c5 it's
complicated but this could this could be
a winning calculation so rook take you
to Brooke take you to d3 c5 and then
Queen d4 that should be winning I don't
think he's getting enough counter play
c6 we win the Queen let's go for that
always nice having this pawn finally
forked him we wanted to do it a long
time ago but so I think c5 is the best
try otherwise if he retreats the Queen
we're just gonna take the rook and be up
a bishop so he just resigns that was
nice okay we at least one a real game
you guys can applaud that was uh that
was nice I think we'll end it there but
yeah I would encourage people even if
you don't usually play only chess
checking out their tools and using them
for your own study I think can be very
effective so hope you guys enjoyed that
and have a good nights
you
[Music]